so it's probably gonna be all of 10
seconds before we get into spoilers just
know that up front so yes at my last
video literally every third comment was
somebody asking me when's the infinity
war review coming out I had a really
packed week life did not cooperate it
took me a week so sue me but I have seen
it I saw it with Liz
so Liz is back and we're gonna talk
infinity war I think we'll talk
non-swiss very quickly um it was good it
was heavy and I think that's about all
we can do for non spoilers so um but I
mean the things been out a week and it
seems very obvious to me that all you
guys have already seen the darn thing um
what let's let's hold off on the heavier
stuff for as long as we can it it was a
packed movie but it didn't feel like
anyone was shortchanged not really no
and here's the thing where's with civil
war I felt there were too many people in
too many places I didn't really feel
that that with this where which is weird
because I'm sure there were more few
there are more days but I think I had
seen more movies leading up to this and
I had stronger character attachments to
some of them and I think even within
this movie characters I didn't really
care much about until now I started to
care about like Wanda Wanda in this
movie man and she unlike other people
she did not have the tape she you know
what up until her this seemed like a
long series of boy the heroes just keep
failing to make the hard choice don't
they
yeah yeah hey boy she was power player
and this I really this this movie I will
say sold me on LAN de cooling because
before I was like I don't really get it
like I guess she's powerful and I see
that but I get her see her struggling
and I'm like now I get it why she
struggles and the ultimate power she has
and how she has to balance the emotional
toll of it with what she has to do so
kudos to the movie for really selling me
on Wanda and kudos to Elizabeth Olsen
for a really powerful nuanced
performance yeah yeah I mean I said
we'll try and hold off on the heavy
stuff I don't think that's gonna work so
this thing has a body count on it I
counted 16 confirmed previously
recurring characters dead by the end of
it yeah dead yes well that's part of the
thing so we've gone okay well that we
well technically did we turn a little
bit dead we talked about this walking
out of the theater for our money and I
can't imagine this is like a big theory
like I imagine this is what most people
are figuring anyone who died from the
half the universe gone move they will be
brought back by the conclusion of the
follow-up Avengers film which probably
means we won't get to see them though
until that movie though well until the
very end because there's they can't have
their little spin-off things well
there's there's two Marvel movies coming
out between now and the follow-up film
one is ant-man the wasp which if I'm if
I'm gonna bet money I say is set before
this yeah that would make sense cuz
otherwise you'd be like oh yeah
otherwise everyone is going on screaming
going why is half the plan it dead we
don't have time for your your fun little
heist adventure yeah fun movie and
the other one feeding into the bonus
credit scene is Captain Marvel now what
we already knew about that movie is that
it is a period pieces actually set in
the 90s
I did not see I know pretty much nothing
so as someone who knows way more than I
said about this that so Captain Marvel
is gonna be set in the 90s which means
that by the end of it she she has to be
somewhere in some state either off world
or somehow unaccounted for to to deal
with the fact that she hasn't shown up
between whatever happens to her in the
90s in her movie and now but it does
seem to set up her returning at the call
of uh of make fury so that's what we
those are the only two were getting
between now and the next Avengers okay
but so yeah so can we get Valkyrie the
side story to like that thing I but I
guess like Tessa Thompson is busy making
made world right now wish you the rest
of you probably call it west world but
you know it's really about yeah we know
but actually I'm a little bit annoyed I
feel like Valkyrie is one of the true
legitimately unaccounted for characters
because most of the others who didn't
appear got a mention like Scott and
Clint a man Hawkeye you know they got
they they got a mention but Valkyrie
unless I'm completely miss Marissa
remembering for writing arc she was with
the Asgardians at the end of that I'm
sure someone will tell us and let us
know I just I honestly done I've got
I've got I've got two complaints in one
half complaint about this movie okay
one of which is an incredible nitpick
but I'll get to that in a second but it
actually kind of started on a weak
footing for me because
it annoys me that coming off the end of
thor ragnarok basically immediately the
Asgardian survivors are decimated I
don't like that I don't like that for
the same reason I don't like alien 3 I
don't like something that opens by
negating it I can open on death I have a
problem with it opening on gating the
victory of whatever came immediately
before it so you know that this whole
thing of get the survivors off of asgard
asgard is its people it's not a place
great now the people are dead too so who
cares yeah it was not my favorite
opening and it's true you can start with
deaths and if it's death if it's like
sacrifice death like I know you didn't
like the last Jedi but I still think it
had a strong opening I think that is an
example of starting with death that is
very powerful this was not no not and
and and additionally it wouldn't have
bothered me so much if like the ship
hadn't been blown up if like maybe maybe
if he like hurled Thor out to space and
then the ship was left there because
then I could go okay well his whole MO
is killing half the population there's a
bunch of people still alive it up let
the ship blow up
so for all intents and purposes until
something tells me otherwise I assume
everybody that was on there who wasn't
for is dead so that annoys okay know
that that's part of that part of what
got me here in the first place okay so
that's my main substantive complaint but
since it was right at the beginning I
was basically fine for the rest of the
movie
my nitpick and I know this is an epic is
this your half or another whole no no
I'll get to the half okay no this is my
nitpick I'm really really really
irritated that Bucky was using a gun
that fired bullets he was in Wakanda I
understand that that's the gun he's used
to
they couldn't outfit him with a gun that
was tactically what he's used to but
fired awesome wakandan technology he's
firing those beers he's firing bullets
which are finite and run out they
couldn't give him an energy weapon
equivalent
that gun but he washed his hair yes you
were you were very happy when he showed
up
Oh excited when Bucky decides to wash
his hair fashion by Bucky shows up go to
the Bucky Barnes School of Cosmetology
yeah yeah he was looking rough but I got
elicited a big squeak cuz I was not
expecting him you had three squeeze in
this movie okay I might have hadn't I
had some mini squeeze you yeah I had
some shakes you ain't you had three
full-on squeeze one was Peter Dinklage
one was Sheree and the other was Peter
Parker yeah I had to suppress the Sheree
squeeze so it didn't result yeah but I
could feel you vibrating in the seat
next to me like oh I think I started
doing that too when I heard the Wakanda
theme going and I knew we were going to
see what you heard well you heard right
you also haven't done many one when you
heard basically the seventies rocking
you knew the guardians were talking yeah
yeah and then I also half suite for Ned
because he was shown right after Peter
so cuz they love Natchez so yes so the
the folks who died who I think are
probably gonna stay dead low key which
and to the prize of a million fangirls
which I like I like him he's done a good
job I've I'm kind of I know I'm I'm
gonna get it I'm kind of done honestly I
I was sorry to see him go but I am okay
with him staying dead because it does
feel like when as guard gone the unless
you especially things like clashing with
like with the [ __ ] kind of gone I'm
yeah just far at each other
but they're not even then like I was
like he's not really gonna get him up
there they're not mortal enemies anymore
yeah and that and I get it I I kind of
get it but I'm I'm ready to let him go
yeah at this point you can't have him
slip into what his role in the Marvel
Comics is which basically to be kind of
an all-purpose wildcard because at for
as far as the movies are because that's
a regression that's undoing his
character too well yeah he already did
that and his rollercoaster so III think
we I think we have gotten as much out of
Loki as can be gotten so he was one well
I'm not necessarily doing them in order
okay
why who who were you thinking come on
yes I was not expect me once we got once
we got into the scene and once we got
her and once we had met the Dementor
what what's make sense the mentor is
guarding like the soulstone like wait
we're gonna come back to him in a second
but yeah I know he's not a real demented
by the way what once once we were in
that scene and basically as soon as it
was said you have to Sakurai something
along I was like he's gonna kill Gamora
so like yeah I called it early in the
scene but prior to that scene I would
not have pegged I thought if any
Guardian Yoshi were gonna was gonna
bring him down like eventually in the
second movie and she was gonna be a big
part of that I didn't know if I thought
she was gonna bring him down but I did
think like if any Guardian isn't gonna
survive this is gonna be Drax I mean he
went away with the half of but again
that I feel like that's a whole separate
category for the for the deaths but yeah
she she legit died and we know she died
cuz he wouldn't have gotten the swag her
own sister for dying didn't yeah I did I
did yeah was she how's your score there
we weren't
like this theater and she's letting me
know that people who I thought most
likely to die none of them died none of
them even like did the melty dusty die
yeah okay if you're done gloating so but
yeah that was that was that was potent
yeah yeah that I almost cried on that
with some cheering well I know where you
did cry but we'll get to that
yeah well yes we'll get to that um so
yeah you mentioned the Dementor aka the
Red Skull who actually you didn't
recognize because you don't really
remember that movie dude and the first
time I know I'm not just the same I also
fell asleep during that but then I
thought again and I like didn't I get it
now Winter Soldier I just never went
back to the first Captain America cuz i
what
don't get me wrong you like the captain
I don't like him as much as everyone
else but like and I like me some Bucky I
actually might like Bucky better than
Captain like even when you you you like
you're broken white boys speaking of who
got shortchanged I mean she wasn't
really in the movie enough we didn't get
to I'm not sure there was more than
could be done with her she did dress
down banner yeah and she never quite met
start right no she hasn't she's gonna do
that too although dr. strange had a
great line dressing him down I protect
your reality douchebag and young quill
got into it with them and like everyone
kind of put him in his place um yeah it
was fun I did enjoy I will enjoy Cherie
doing that but yes so the red skull
showing up that was kind of a fun cameo
and I I have a suspicion cuz Hugo
Weaving and said he didn't want to come
back and play this part again and I will
bet money that it was CGI this time
last time it was makeup and he hated it
so I will bet you they did motion
capture CGI on him this time okay but I
I think they put him in there just so
fans will stop speculating about what
happened to him at the end of Captain
America because what happened at the end
of him and that he like took hold of the
tesseract and like vanished like it
looked like he got teleported
god-knows-where into space but we didn't
know what happened and there were a
million you know fan theories oh he's
this - that he'll come back and I feel
like having him up here this is just so
I'm like this is what happened to him
stop asking so I was thinking about that
in terms of like the stones yes and it
all seems to be about like sacrifice
giving up the stone or like
relinquishing a stones control huh to
some degree oh well I mean maybe not on
everyone but like you know like Loki how
to say okay I'm gonna sacrifice you know
the stone yeah Doctor Strange did for
Tony Stark
actually we skipped over it that's my
half complaint I don't buy that right
now but there was something you'd like I
just don't like I don't buy given the
short time they knew each other the
relationship that they had you need the
reality but maybe and the one future he
saw where they win he knows that he has
to give up this that that's why it's
only a half because there were things he
said about we're in the endgame now or
it was the only year the only way or
something something to the cover that I
think yes I think he knew something that
he wasn't able to communicate so I'm
leaving the door open for that to not
continue to be a complaint but right now
as presented I don't buy it
but I'm hoping the follow-up film covers
its bases with that but I don't really
have I was but I even liked so okay so
did he collect the rainbow was he like
gathering skittles in his
love taste the rainbow taste the rainbow
basically yes oh I don't know I don't
know thanks for marketing its taste the
rainbow that's what the movie was
missing danos licking the garland I
actually I was surprising some of the
stuff that I liked that I thought was
gonna be more throw away I actually kind
of liked the fan OSes followers they
were solid as villains and the the one
guy to them the one yet and the one guy
who got defeated on the spaceship that
was cathartic oh there's some there are
some pretty good action sequences and
there's nothing that like blew me away
on the scale of say the airport fight
from civil war or the or the mbaku to
chala fight from from black panther like
there weren't any sequences that knocked
me on my butt the way some of those have
in the past but they were good they were
all really good and they were intense
and I could follow them and yeah it was
it was good action stuff yeah so yeah
why don't we talk about what where we
both cried yeah so Peter was my first
squeak yeah and he was also where I
cried when he starts like clutching
himself and being like historic I don't
fear to feel too well and was like and
then he starts begging and that's just
because no one else back but he's a he's
a yes scared kid and he I know he's
supposed to be like 16 or something but
a lot of times I was like you could be
one of my fifth graders you could be one
of my preschoolers he's just endearingly
young and so yeah the funny thing was
somebody had dropped the comment and
what surprisingly I managed to avoid
spoilers in the week that it took me to
watch this thing and so allow me to
thank the commenters on my channel
nobody was a jerk and spoiler but one
person did put one thing they put I
don't want to go which I looked at that
kind of [ __ ] to my head because that
that is a that is aligned famously from
a scene in Doctor Who that makes a lot
of people sad and does not make me
nearly as sad as it's supposed to but
when this happened in this movie our
Washington went now see here's the
difference because when doctor who did
it and I'm not gonna go into detail
about what the scene is because I'm
still catching you up on it you haven't
seen this one yet when doctor who did it
it came off as why me when this didn't
he came off as pleading animus that was
hurt he like ripped me apart
oh I loved so much I mean I already
loved him from spider-man homecoming but
Oh
slayed me I mean it was it was really
hard this this was more heartbreaking
though I
I think Gamora made me more mad I was
then ready to go oh I'm dull we forgot
to mention for handle that definite
confirmed death as opposed to just
assumed vision vision yeah visions gone
yeah holy cow yeah I mean there's some
part of me that is holding on to Gamora
and being like me me but now she's and
she's in that other light realm so yeah
I mean she yeah she's dead okay so yeah
that was oh speaking of the Gemara
oh my god little Gamora was so cute oh
my goodness and so tough and I also did
I mean I called it when he gave her that
blade that she was gonna use it on him
later I was just hoping it would make it
to the second movie injured
yeah not so much so much so we've been
we've been putting off let's talk about
Thanos mr. Chen is ridiculous
were you ever able to get over the chin
or did your eyes just zero in on it
every time it took a while eventually I
got over the chin cuz you know this
little glove but anyway yeah his chin
was ridiculous and I'm glad that quill
made fun of it because oh cool got some
good name line also I love space rabbit
so are you just in futures is gonna
refer to Thor as wrinkled chin skittle
glove thought of seaweed not that yeah
sorry yeah yeah I like it wrinkles
wrinkles I was actually really impressed
with him as a villain and I was he
worked
other than the ridiculous chin which
they're stuck with from the comics but I
would I was surprised at how much screen
time he had this action honestly was
almost more his movie than anybody
else's and he's got some like he had
some weighty heavy moments he wasn't
just a villain that was like oh I'm
gonna destroy half the universe here I
go yeah he was thinking about it like
the gomorrah scene was touching cuz he
he sacrificed yeah he he he's doing what
he feels is necessary and he feels the
weight of what of this path that he's
taken which is actually an interesting
interpretation of the character cuz he's
not he doesn't normally have the same
mentality we talked a little about this
i think when we talked about the the
trailer oh yeah
which is that in the comics he just has
an obsession with death like he's in
romantic love with the physical
embodiment of death and he yeah but he
he kills half the universe basically
just to try and press her he doesn't
it's not like a life mission
he's he's kind of a he's kind of just a
nihilist
he's a nihilist with an absurd ego which
makes action for a bit of an interesting
dynamic in the comics but it's different
from what they gave us in the movies
whereas in the movies he he believes he
is making the hard choice that no one
else will which here's the thing this
and this is what I had slight issue with
is it reminded me a lot of ego well I
guess only oh I didn't make that
connection because egos thing was to
literally make everything in the
universe him I get that but I was also
the like pull of I have to destroy
things I don't really want to it was
enough that not that I'm super bothered
me but I was like I wanted I was enough
that I was like why I think will like
being like haven't we been here before
like can I just kill you a dad like yeah
so spoilers for lots of other movies if
you've seen this movie thing you already
know that stuff because in the ship
comparing family drama oh my god this or
star-lord interactions weren't great and
one of my favorite parts also the Ben &
Jerry's Avenger flavors were fantastic I
mean we we're Vermonters so yeah you see
Ben and Jerry's this kind of a yeah we
we take pride in that
yeah but yeah danos overall and actually
it was funny I don't I don't know if you
were so again the screen wasn't but I
think at the end normally at the end of
these they say the Avengers will return
at the end of this has just said Thanos
will return I did not see that but yeah
yeah yeah well yeah cuz he liked it but
we had this discussion when you look at
who's left over and this cannot be a
coincidence
it's pretty much the original game yeah
I mean it's all yes it all
all of them - Nick Fury if you want to
count him but he isn't an on-the-ground
guy anyway but aside from that yeah
they're all still here so a original
Avengers assembled group was Hulk Iron
Man Thor Captain America Black Widow and
Hawkeye who who didn't appear but they
didn't show up they didn't show him
going melty so one would assume he's
still around yeah
so yeah that's they they are all still
there and yeah you know that it's all
it's all the newer folks which given
that this this is setting up the well
first of all this is like the 10 years
since the since the first Ironman so
it's like the ten year anniversary film
almost but also I have the rough ten
hair reading and guys like that is that
is like the worst you know Bad Girls
Night Out movie yeah you thought Charles
your hands and had a rough night in that
other movie but it's probably setting
setting it up to have that core group be
more or less at the center in the next
one and I'm sticking to this not all of
them are gonna make it through that one
okay damn F and I and I might
grandfather myself through on the claim
that it's a two-part story I don't know
yeah okay yeah no I'm not saying I'll be
right I'll just say I'll be less wrong
baby girl that's my goal in life just be
less wrong than I currently am um I'm
trying to think of other things to talk
about yeah like step up for Wanda Peter
broke my heart
gamora death made me really mad glad
that nobody was still around - yes
very nice and it was kind of touching
that she realized first like what they
know so did yeah and I am matic will
though because I was like they had it
they had it it was coming off like and
like nebulas should have punched him out
but she I was dealing with feelings and
well defeated by feels I get it as one
heck of a girl yeah but that that was
still a little bit of a frustrating
always like doing on your side cuz you
had all the quips with Thor and it was
great and all the silly gels you don't
know dude boy oh my goodness when you do
that yeah yeah you can you know what you
can be disappeared for a while for that
yeah you go off into oblivion and think
about what you did young man did you
have to take Peter with you like man oh
but yeah it was it was brutal like we
just kind of sat there for a while and
we were you know I I think it was very
wise of them to not have a mid credit on
this one to only have a very odd tailor
the credit cousin I think you need to
sit there and process for about the
length that I credits running yeah yeah
cuz you still I mean I was still trying
to process some of the other deaths that
had happened you know like I hadn't
fully processed Gamora and you know
vision had just gone and you know so
much had happened it was
action-packed and a lot to follow so
yeah Oh another thing I did like the
scene where Black Widow and a Quay and
it's launder you're fighting the
villainous woman and this is what Conda
this is what they do the women dance
together like you are gonna get your
butt handed to you lady like you are
gonna be gotten because this is what
they do even when they have different
they're not like the boys in civil war
that our squad Lee squad Lee no they
band together yeah yeah they did they
took her down really well and uh it was
interesting watching the dynamic with
with banner and basically after he gets
his butt kicked the Hulk sulking the
whole movie and refusing to show up
he'll be back he will be back but he's
like that was that was probably the one
special effect that it was like wow
that's that is floating head syndrome
holy crap but yeah it was a funny image
for how small his head looked in that
book fan Wow you pulled it off well yeah
and I mean he's there pretty much the
only maybe couple we have left other
than pepper and Tony yeah Jessica's a
vision and Wanda and Gomorrah and
star-lord and I mean Lee I mean while I
two challahs lady didn't appear so
well I mean that there are some that
again it reinforces the the ones who
they're definitely coming back like half
of them have their their next movies
already announced like we know
spider-man homecoming is getting a
sequel we know Black Panthers getting a
sequel and yeah you better believe it
and and I cannot imagine they're all
gonna be prequel set before this yeah
yeah yeah I mean you would be a fool to
kill off some a mostly T'Challa but also
also Peter because real yeah we all love
him ending Oh
total random thing that got very smart
of them to get the Stan Lee cameo out of
the way early so that yeah
so we weren't looking for it yeah yeah
yeah and it it felt like a fitting line
what's the matter how could you kids
never seen a spaceship before thanks
Stan hey uh some day I got I got a like
review all the Stanley appearances and
decide on my favorite yeah mm-hmm I
don't know if I'll ever do a little set
of that there was there were things that
came out about him in the last few
months that I'm a little like now his
appearances and these are brief enough
that they don't create an issue for me
but they are it is it has become a
little yeah man yeah I didn't I I think
I heard rumor and I didn't read it yet
but oh yeah I can guess what you mean
yeah you don't have to read it boy that
one do it different gender you know I
really been drained that Peter Dinklage
cameo that was fun that was that was go
animate I like I like that they said
actually I cuz I knew he was in the
movie but they had a nice that and then
I forgot the heaven now who was playing
so when as soon as Thor said you know we
need to go and and the dwarves will
Forge me a new weapon I'm like that'll
be Peter Dinklage but of course he's a
giant through
galavant oh we're very small Giants were
just very large tools yeah that was that
was my favorite cameo probably I mean I
guess there was a little more than a
cameo but I was a little more
substantive than a cameo but yeah I know
that was there when I liked the group
hair Knoll I mean I knew it was kind of
coming but oh it was so nice you finally
put down the video game I'm so proud of
how much of a flashback to do because of
your schools did that give you there
aren't they aren't on electronics a lot
they're not really allowed but like they
would be though yeah that is right if
nothing else you recognize the mentality
yeah sometimes you play the games on
your phone I have no idea what this
woman is tough I am
[Laughter]
yeah I don't think there was there was
any appearance of any character in this
film that didn't work they all work for
what they had them come in and do
whether it was big whether it was little
yeah and some of them were though I like
just seeing mbaku show up oh gosh some
alien monster dogs with his with his big
beating sir little like shake oh my gosh
look yeah so there were that being said
I did want a little more T'Challa in
this and I obviously I always want more
Cherie but I guess she was busy she was
doing very detailed work which I kind of
almost wonder like is there any way she
could have messed with the stone and if
that will come about I doubt it but
maybe whatever she saw while she was
working on it will give her insight into
the stone that will come into the next
one okay
so we've still he's door still got his
axe right yeah what do we got going into
this we got the original team yep we've
got the original team we've got Captain
Marvel probably coming in oh yeah she
will definitely be there I'm guessing
minion wasp oh come on I come in maybe
they'll slide in Hawkeye I'm hoping for
some Valkyrie um you've got a lot of
well I mean actually know a lot of the
mad people disappeared like we'll um so
that stinks but the one they've got a
mad nebula so that's where something
yeah there were there were characters
who I thought were gonna come back who
basically got talked off because the
last time we saw the Power Stone at the
end of the first Guardians movie was put
in the hand of the Nova Corps which
included included folks like fun people
yeah Glenn Close and john c reilly but
we just that's the first stone that
Thanos has and he just and we just hear
about how he massacred Xander to get it
so yeah we can assume they're dead lots
of death good movie though
yeah lots of death vote for her a movie
that that ends I mean with the bad guy
we not only winning and accomplishing
but like literally getting exactly what
he wanted sitting down to watch a
sunrise and smiling thank you
oh good movie yeah that managed to have
that ending and wash his hair so like
what oh what a good movie it is cuz like
he was like I'm gonna wash my I got some
I got some wakandan Herbal Essences so
you know it's the good stuff oh the
other thing I knew like once we saw a
bracelet I was like oh that's that
Cherie
oh yeah cuz
and I was just like what I heard the
music I was like I know where we're
going I'm speaking of settings so like
settings of worlds and whatnot like what
did makan is still my favorite yeah um
any world that you thought were world
were well done or intriguing or whatever
um I didn't expect a stone to be on
warmer warmer and yeah right yeah um I
thought she was lying about that I
thought she was like pulling a Princess
Leia it did seem a little too
straightforward but then we sort of
learn about the sacrifice that's
involved yeah so it made a mission stop
there was nothing he could do you know
yeah because she kind of more or less
said that yeah I'm not sacrifice you you
love nothing so you can't get this I
think you should probably believe that I
the the setting of Titan which is where
Thanos takes on Iron Man and spider-man
and half the Guardians that was a
setting that was fine and then was lent
a surprising amount of buoyancy just
with that one little sort of flash back
to how it used to be that Fanus gives us
that glimpse and I'm looking forward to
more reality shifting and yeah I want to
hang out in dwarf worlds a little more
yeah I know it's torn up but there's
nothing I mean that's it that's the
rough part is like all these worlds we
went to are pretty much decimated
already when we get there yeah so well
Conda is not in great shape but you
didn't totally decimate it so that's
that made me happy they still have their
source of power so that something I'm
guessing that will help them in the next
movie I would imagine
yeah cuz I mean yes they've lost their
leader but they still have the brains
behind it with Sheree cuz I'm gonna
guess she didn't disappear we would have
seen it yeah I assume that anyone who we
didn't see did you have a and death
thing is you have a lot of brainy
characters left yes because we sell
we've still got Bruce we've got Tony
we've got Sheree yeah we've got some of
the some of the big thing key people
yeah still around yeah I think I think
we've touched on just about everything
yeah I think so okay well let's thank
you so much for singing with me and
thank you for indulging me for one of
these so folks I was gonna ask have you
seen infinity more and had the highest
opening weekend both domestic and
international in history it made no I
didn't really
hey yeah I'm feeling I work so I was
getting a touch at the box office it
made more in its opening weekend than
just dis Lee did domestically in its
entire run so having just seen Justice
League yeah that's that's okay so I
don't have to ask if you've seen it of
course you've seen it I'm late to this
party what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as support me on patreon follow
me on Twitter listening to our podcast
links to all that yeah links to all that
stuff is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]